et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
aurélien pradié bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être à vélo les 8 et 10 le
sécrétaire général des républicains on
est enceinte on n'en veut ni pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne nationale représentée par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour julien bonjour oriane bonjour je
suis produit et aurélien pradié on
commence par la crise sanitaire puisque
le taux d'incidence ne baissent plus le
variant delta inquiète il progresse et
la vaccination est toujours insuffisante
c'est en tout cas ce que dit le
gouvernement dans les échos ce matin
gabriel attal le porte parole du
gouvernement dit nous avons fait jusqu'à
maintenant le choix de la conviction
plutôt que de la coercition mais cela
pourrait évoluer est-ce que vous
soutiendrez la vaccination obligatoire
si jamais le gouvernement prend cette
décision
je pense que c'est une c'est une erreur
les menaces en matière de santé publique
ça n'a jamais fonctionné et ça ne
fonctionne pas dans un moment où on a
une crise de confiance absolument majeur
on a un sujet qui aujourd'hui l'accès à
la vaccination pour pour nos concitoyens
je suis pas sûr que ce soit si simple
que ça d'accéder aujourd'hui à la
vaccination
je le vois moi dans les territoires on a
à mon sens baisser la garde sur l'élan
qu'il fallait donner à nos concitoyens
pour aller se faire vacciner sur la
facilité aussi aller se faire vacciner
je dois avouer que j'y comprends plus
tout à fait grand-chose sur qui est
prioritaire qu'il n'est plus acquis au
louvre qui on n'ouvre pas oui mais sauf
que dans la réalité ce n'est pas si
évident que ça et je penche ya pas de
critiques inutiles dans ce que je dis je
dis simplement qu'il faut que à chaque
fois nous soyons bien attentif est bien
certain que partout la vaccination est
accessible le plus facilement qu'il soit
le deuxième sujet c'est de redonner
confiance à nos concitoyens
moi je ne crois pas à la contrainte non
pas parce que je suis aussi la
vaccination
pas du tout mais seulement parce que je
pense que ça fait l'effet inverse ça
casse la confiance et nous sommes à un
moment nous avons besoin de cette
confiance est donc accompagnons nos
concitoyens la vaccination expliquant ce
qui doit être expliqué que pour
certaines professions en particulier
nous ayons une vaccination obligatoire
sanaryenne nouveau ça existe déjà
notamment pour des professionnels qui
travaillent dans la petite enfance pour
d'autres types de pathologie mais pour
l'horreur et épate par exemple elles
sont laissons pas cette vaccination
obligatoire carrière jean castex dit
c'est pas admissible que le virant que
le virus se rendent dans les ehpad via
les soignants est ce que là il a raison
c'est pas admissible pour les résidents
mais c'est pas admissible pour les
soignants non plus qu'ils sont qui sont
en danger je suis assez favorable à ce
que on puisse avoir des contraintes
selon les métiers
en revanche que l'on ait des contraintes
dès lors qu'on est simple citoyen je n'y
crois pas et ça m'inquiète parce que
cette hygiène isation de la société on a
souvent eu ce débat je crois même ici
d'ailleurs avec vous est quelque chose
qui peut être rassurant a priori mais
qui à mon avis sur du moyen et du long
terme et plus dévastateur qu'autre chose
mais oui pour les soignants mais la vie
des soignants c'est comme ça pour pour
les soignants je les dis d'ailleurs il
ya déjà que pour le reste de la
population a priori on n'est pas parti
on n'est pas parti pour nom mais
attention au toboggan
quand on commence à expliquer que pour
fréquenter tel lieu il faudra une
vaccination que pour faire telle
activité il faudrait une vaccination
au final il faudrait pas qu'on ait une
vaccination contrainte sans vouloir le
dire l'autre moyen
ce serait de rendre les tests pcr payant
les tests pcr de confort on va dire
qu'ils permettent aux français d'éviter
la d'éviter la vaccination ou de la
contourner sinon n'ont pas l'usagé
est-ce que là aussi vous pensez que
c'est plutôt une bonne solution une
bonne piste
quel est notre objectif aujourd'hui
notre objectif c'est s'assurer qu'on ne
rebascule pas dans une situation
ingérable
or aujourd'hui vous le lisiez les
raisons d'être rassurés il ya aussi des
raisons d'être vigilant on a des
départements d'ailleurs des territoires
dans lesquels on a une augmentation de
la contamination est donc je pense pas
que ce soit le moment de jouer les
petits comptables
on a un vrai sujet sur la dépense
publique de santé depuis plusieurs
semaines et plusieurs mois qui a explosé
on est bien d'accord mais en revanche il
faut que nos concitoyens puissent se
tester le plus simplement possible tant
qu on était encore dans une période
fragile
donc je ne suis pas très favorable à ce
qu'on me pose c'est qu'on traîne pas
parce que je ne crois pas que c'est ce
qui amènera nos concitoyens aujourd'hui
réticents vers la vaccination
je ne crois pas que ce soit ça qui
permettent de les pousser à se vacciner
questions sur les moyens peut être
réutilisé on sait que la chancelière
allemande angela merkel s'est posé la
question de nouvelles restrictions aux
frontières est ce que vous seriez vous
soyez favorable aussi un durcissement de
ces de ces restrictions pour éviter là
encore une nouvelle vague
oui je suis totalement d'ailleurs les
républicains depuis l'origine avant dit
que nous avions un sujet avec les
frontières et vous souvenez vous à
l'époque le ministre verrons-nous riait
au nez en dix ans
en le virus n'a pas de passeport ils ont
tardivement d'ailleurs fait ce que nous
leur demandions de faire donc oui nous
avons un sujet avec nos frontières je
pense qu'il faut être beaucoup plus
contraignant sur l'entrée et les sorties
et les sorties parce que là on est sur
un choix liberté quand vous partez en
vacances à l'étranger
ça m'a coûté si vous ne voulez pas vous
faire vacciner vous ne partez pas en
vacances à l'étranger si ce le pays qui
vous accueille à poser cette contrainte
là ça ne changera rien fondamentalement
à votre vie c'est un choix que vous
faites et si vous le faites je pense que
vous pouvez assumer cette contrainte y
compris pour ceux qui viennent dans
notre pays parce que je le rappelle mais
un des sujet fondamental de l'explosion
de cette pandémie a été liée à la
circulation des êtres des êtres humains
sur sur notre planète et donc avoir à
nos frontières une sécurisation
sanitaires ça me paraît être la moindre
des choses
les dernières questions là dessus
puisque ce matin gabriel attali l'emploi
l'expression de fractures vaccinale il
dit je crains qu'une fracture vaccinale
le divise les français ceux qui sont
vaccinées ne tolérerons pas de nouvelles
restrictions liées au refus de
vaccination de certains autres vous
aussi vous la redoute et cette facture
etc snal moi je redoute beaucoup
l'ensemble des fracturations de notre
pays je sors de trois mois de campagne
en occitanie je fais soixante dix mille
kilomètres j'ai rencontré les milliers
de femmes et d'hommes et je n'ai vu que
des fractures
les fractures entre les jeunes et les
plus âgés une fracture entre ceux qui
vivent bien et ceux qui vivent dans une
situation de pauvreté des fractures
entre ceux qui peuvent se soigner et
ceux qui ont du mal à accès avant
d'avoir accès à des soins
pardon de lire mais une fracture aussi
entre ceux qui ont été les premiers à
avoir accès à la vaccination et ceux qui
n'ont pas été les premiers à avoir accès
à la vaccination
bref où il s'est fracturé l'allemagne
est mais gabriel attal il doit
comprendre que comme porte parole du
gouvernement il a une part de
responsabilité dans les fractures dans
notre pays souffre depuis plusieurs
années je crois que ce gouvernement
emmanuel macron en particulier
parmi ses plus grande faute celle
d'avoir fracturé la société à bien des
égards et ça vaut y compris sur les
questions de stratégie sanitaire
on va revenir sur les régionales
évidemment mais d'abord on va parler de
la réforme des retraites
autre possible fracture qui pourrait
venir bousculer la france dans les
prochains dans les prochains moins c'est
la petite musique de la réforme des
retraites qui est revenue du côté du
gouvernement
alors évidemment aucune décision n'est
prise pour l'instant mais le président
de la république pourrait annoncer ce
mois-ci la poursuite de plusieurs
réformes dont 7 des retraites vient un
report de l'âge légal à 64 ans dès la
fin d'année
alors question simple est ce que pour
vous c'est opportun de faire ça avant la
présidentielle
écoutez on peut peut-être se parler un
peu franchement c'est même le but c'est
un but et bien donc nous allons le faire
tout ça est une blague mauvaise blague
tout ça est une blague
quel sens le lendemain d'une élection
régionale perdu pour le président de la
république comme aucun président n'a
jamais perdu une élection de ce niveau
là il annonce par quelques entrefilets
dans la presse qu' il va reprendre le
chemin de la réforme comme pour enjamber
l'échec de la mission régionale
ce n'est que cela l'objectif que cela il
faut être absolument lussier politiciens
pour vous c'est une petite manoeuvre
politique et sur un sujet qui ne peut
pas souffrir de manoeuvre politique la
question la réforme des retraites est
une question colossale pour notre pays
c'est sûrement un des grands sujets de
justice sociale dans notre pays pour les
décennies qui viennent
c'est un des grands sujets de solidarité
nationale dans notre pays pour les
décennies qui viennent on ne traite pas
de cette question avec autant de
négligence et autant d'esprits
politiciens la réforme des retraites
c'est pas une tactique politicienne la
réforme des retraites c'est revoir
l'architecturé des solidarités et la
justice sociale dans notre pays et ça
mérite autre chose que un amendement au
coin d'une table dans le projet de loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale
tout ça n'est pas sérieux au mieux n'est
pas sérieux au pire est une manière de
prendre les français pour des imbéciles
alors c'est mérite autre chose qu'un
amendement mais est-ce que ça mérite un
vrai débat est ce que ce débat doit
avoir lieu avant la présidentielle
vous vous souvenez tous de même que le
cias est un vrai texte un vrai débat là
vous dites oui effectivement il faut
qu'on se pose cette question rapidement
enfin nous n'avons
vous ni moi d'aidé mémoire de poisson
rouge il ya quelques mois nous avons eu
un débat sur la réforme des retraites j
ai participé des dizaines et des
centaines d'heures avec mes collègues
nous avons fait des propositions
d'ailleurs dans l'est républicain pour
non seulement allonger l'âge de départ à
la retraite mais et recréer un vrai
dispositif universel de pénibilité sont
vos propositions
c'est le président de la république et
son équipe gouvernementale qui au final
on a abandonné cette réforme ont
souhaité l'abandonner politiquement
c'est pas nous qui l'avons abandonné ce
sont eux qui l'ont abandonné et vous
croyez que aujourd'hui ah non à peine un
an de l'élection présidentielle
c'est à dire en gros on a six mois
devant nous puisque élections
présidentielles va très vite arriver
vous croyez vraiment qu'on ouvre un
chantier aussi important enfin
franchement non seulement c'est pas
sérieux mais en plus je le dis comme je
le pense c'est prendre les
parlementaires pour des imbéciles
ça emmanuel macron en a l'habitude mais
c'est aussi prendre les français pour
des services et une partie de la réforme
bull vous l'avez bien saisi parce que là
on parle d'une de réforme paramétrique
qui vise à redresser les finances les
finances et l'équilibré du système des
retraites mais qui ne galvaude
absolument pas là l'autre partie de la
réforme plus systémique dont on parle de
la fusion des régimes de retraite et
finalement de revoir l'architecturé
ce que vous décrivez c'est comme si en
fait le président de la république
faisait soldes de tout compte avec 7
avec l'idée d'allonger la
la durée de cotisation mais ce cas ce
n'est pas le cas et bien sûr c'est
qu'ils n'abandonnent pas n'abandonne pas
le reste de la réforme
et il a bien entendu pas sauf que mon
espoir c'est que d'arzon mais daniel
mach rond ne soit plus président de la
république est-ce que vous avez pas
nathan qui ont dit qu'ils coupent
l'herbe sous le pied finalement non du
rêve et une candidature à droite on
pense à xavier bertrand qui a proposé
avec la proposer la même chose avec
cette histoire là on ne la raconte
depuis quatre ans ça fait quatre ans
qu'emmanuel macron en faisant des petits
coups politiques daniel mach ronces et
c'est un politicien de marketing dont
qui considère qu'en faisant des coups
politiques en faisant des appels du pied
il arrive à draguer un électorat c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe et personne
n'est dupe sur le fait qu'il prend les
français pour des imbéciles en leur
annonçant des réformes qui n'aura pas
lui et là où j'ai une divergence avec ce
que vous évoquez c'est que moi je
considère que la réforme des retraites
c'est un bloc on n'est pas des on est
pas là pour faire des ajustements sur la
réforme des retraites ouvrant un compte
quand même que la question de l'âge de
départ à la retraite va changer la vie
de centaines de millions de nos
concitoyens et que donc on ne peut pas
traiter cette question si on ne traite
pas en même temps la deuxième jambe qui
est celle de la justice sociale avec un
olivier traite qui est la pénibilité
c'est le régime universel de paix limité
que nous avions proposée c'est aussi la
fin des régimes spéciaux où est passé le
le matamore emmanuel macron qui montrait
ses muscles en disant vous allez voir ce
que vous allez voir je vais réformer ce
pays en profondeur pour des chroniques
depuis quatre ans il joue le comédien le
grand réformateur d'aider des grands
soirs et au final on atterrit sur un
amendement dans un projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale pour
réformer les retraites
enfin franchement si c'est pour être un
petit gestionnaire et mauvais
gestionnaires de cette manière là c'est
pas la peine d'être président de la
république
emmanuel macron n'a qu'à être chef de
bureau à bercy et j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les chefs de bureaux et pas
président de la république
allez on va parler des régionales et de
la question de l'abstention julien
notamment oui alors président de
l'assemblée nationale l'avait vu richard
ferrand a annoncé mardi en conférence
des présidents la création d'une mission
sur les ressorts et raison de
l'abstention c'est vrai que tout le
monde
toutes formations confondues s'est
retrouvé face à une inattention inconnu
jusqu'à jusqu'à présent en record que
doit-on faire selon vous pour
redynamiser la démocratie c'est un sujet
sur lequel il faut que nous fassions
preuve de beaucoup d'humilité mais moi
je me pose une question d'abord je ne
crois pas que les ressorts de
l'abstention soit lié à la difficulté à
voter vote électronique le vote sur
plusieurs jours puis ça s'est très bien
moi je veux bien qu'on en discute même
si j'ai beaucoup de réserve mais c'est
pas ça le sujet le sujet c'est à quel
point aujourd'hui il ya un vide entre la
vie politique et la vie de nos
concitoyens moi je les ai vécus en
faisant la campagne que j'ai menées je
vais vous dire je pense qu'il n'est
principale raison c'est le comportement
politique et je sais que c'est difficile
à dire vous allez me trouver dur mais je
le pense véritablement en vous le 10 ans
la manière dont les politiques se
comporte depuis plusieurs années dont
ils trahissent leur famille politique
avec autant de facilité dont ils jouent
les girouettes avec autant de banalités
dont ils ne défendent plus aucune
conviction
l'effacement de la droite et de la
gauche il feinte aux soins des grandes
valeurs des grands clivages politiques
des idéologies qui pour moi ont un sens
positif
cette idée que tout se vaut c'est la
grande idée macro nist et je pense que
le bal des trahisons depuis plusieurs
mois plusieurs années le val qui en
parlant des traîtres tout ce qui est la
macro ni est faite de traîtres de droite
et de traîtres de gauche je sais que
quand je prononce mon en hurlant disant
d'enfants vous êtes dur excusez moi mais
on est quand même dans une époque on
n'ose plus dire les choses
quelqu'un qui est capable de passer
d'une famille politique en une autre
pour avoir un poste ministériel
s'appelle un traître politique mais les
choses en plus charles darmanin en est
la plus grande incarnation oui il n'est
pas le seul
il a rejoint beaucoup d'autres ses amis
ou ses ennemis de gauche dans le même
gouvernement
je dis pas pour le plaisir d'être
agréable est que je lis parce que moi je
les ai vécues sur le terrain vraiment à
quel point nos concitoyens sont
désespérés de voir que les politiques
étaient devenus incapables de défendre
des convictions même quand c'est
difficile et je pense que tout cela à
banaliser a dégradé l'idée que l'on se
fait de la politique et je pense que
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
plus de la moitié nos concitoyens ne
vont plus voter c'est un lent délitement
du congo ont commandé pour pour changer
ça monsieur pradier parce que la
trahison fait partie de l'histoire
politique elle en est même là
consubstantiel quasiment non pas la tri
raison vous trompez pardon de vous dire
elle fait partie de l'histoire
polynésiens balle est à dire ça non non
non il ya une différence
un tube non pas la trahison des idées
politiques je dîne pas qu'elle est que
ça je dis qu'elle fait partie de la
halle dans l'histoire je veux vraiment
insister sur ce point si si vous me
permettez non cette époque que nous
connaissons ne ressemble pas aux époques
passées il ya quelques décennies
vous ne passiez pas d'une famille
politique à une autre que dans votre
propre camp vous tiriez des coups de
poignard dans le dos pour réussir une
chose mais vous ne quittez pas votre
famille politique pour aller dans une
autre famille politique avec autant de
banalités vous rendez compte tout de
même qu' il ya des femmes et des hommes
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont ministres la
république dans ce gouvernement qui
quelques jours avant de devenir ministre
bataillé à l'assemblée nationale contre
le gouvernement et est ce que vous ne
pensez pas vraiment je le dis que tout
cela dégrade le comportement plus
profondes
un peu fait-on pour résoudre somme c'est
bien d'abord on dit que désormais passer
d'une crèmerie à une autre c'est pas
banal que ils ont ils déjà et le
gouvernement d'ouverture c'est nicolas
sarkozy comme il ya une différence entre
le gouvernement d'ouverture et
aujourd'hui ce en même temps est-ce que
l'on peut un instant c'est peut-être pas
très concret ce que je dis mais c'est à
mon sens la clé comprendre que la fin
des convictions politiques
ce que la macro ni à théoriser la fin de
la droite et de la gauche c'est eux
c'est un poison pour notre démocratie
nous avons besoin d'une droite et d'une
gauche de radicalité
on entend beaucoup cette idée qu'il faut
retrouver de la radicalité dans le dans
le paysage politique c'est votre
sentiment
je n'ai
jamais prononcé le mot de radicalité
mais en tous les cas de de clarté de
clarté et de sincérité et il faut faire
basculer le camp de l'opportunisme vers
le camp des convictions oui ça je le
crois beaucoup et je peux vous assurer
que même en occitanie en menant la
campagne que j'ai mené j'ai vu des
femmes et des hommes espérer qu'il y ait
enfin des responsables politiques qui
disent qu'ils sont fidèles à leurs
convictions même quand il ya un peu de
tempête est ce qu emmanuel macron il a
raison de ne pas tirer de conséquences
nationales de ce scrutin en disant c'est
une élection locale ou est ce que pour
vous elles doivent être tirées ce que
par exemple il doit réunir les
parlementaires en congrès d'ici la fin
de mois de juillet je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il ya un lien entre le résultat
d'élections et la réunion du congrès
est-ce qu'il devait s'exprimer est-ce
qu'il doit s'expliquer devant les
parlementaires devant les parlementaires
mais devant les français enfin n'est pas
forcément congrès pour vous n'entendez
pas en tout cas je vende pas le congrès
pour le plaisir de réunir le congrès il
faut que derrière il ya une vraie
réforme
si ya pas de propositions de réforme ça
ne sert à rien à rien le congrès c'est
pour écoute emmanuel macron je peux
l'écouter la télé ça me va très bien
pendant faut le dire mais en revanche si
congrès réunies pour transformer et la
constitution et les grands éléments de
notre pays pourquoi pas quant à la
question de savoir s'il doit considérer
que cette élection ne le regardait pas
enfin c'est quand même inouï
il a envoyé des bataillons de ministres
dans les régions pour mener la bataille
des parlementaires ont été candidats y
compris dans la région ont pris des
claques électorales dès le premier tour
enfin c'est quand même il faut être
totalement perche est totalement
déconnecté enfermé à l'elysée pour se
poser car tu donnes dans une étude de
deux docks sa sortie sur les raisons
pour lesquelles les gens ne sont pas
allés voter
60% disent qu'avant tout c'est la
responsabilité des partis c'est pas des
manuels macron mais enfin et c'est cette
époque et curieuse dans cette époque
personne n'est responsable de rien
président de la république issu un échec
électoral colossal enfin je vous
rappelle que certaines ses ministres non
pape de ses miss n'ont pas passé le
premier tour d'élections régionales pas
passé le premier tour elle moi dans ma
région de démissionner cela m'a coûté
une époque où il y avait un code
d'honneur en politique je sais que là le
mot que je prononçais sociaux en
comprenant ce qu est un code d'honneur
quand on était par exemple ministre
l'intérieur et qu'on était incapable
d'assurer la la diffusion des
propagandes électorales
on ne voudrait pas dire à la
représentation nationale excusez moi je
suis désolé c'est inacceptable je
recommencerai plus non on oublie la
manade a démissionné pour vous mais
c'était une époque par dont on ne sait
pas si longtemps il y avait ce code
d'honneur paris ce matin les scinder sa
démission considère que s'il avait une
certaine idée de l'honneur nous
n'aurions pas besoin de le demander ils
démissionneraient lui-même rendez compte
que le ministre de l'intérieur chargé
des élections a été
pardon je vais être brutal
pas lire comme sage à venir un foutu
mais incapable d'assurer la distribution
des propagandes électorales
enfin c'est pas un petit sujet tout de
même moi j'aime préfet de région qui
fait appeler dans ma région la veille du
deuxième tour en disant écoutez monsieur
le député bon il ya autour de 30% des
propagandes électorales qui seront pas
distribués mais les gens pourront le
consulter sur un site internet
excusez moi mais une grande démocratie
comme la nôtre quelques soucis à se
faire et donc pour répondre pleinement à
votre question
willy à venir entre emmanuel macron et
cet échec électoral
et s'il ne veut pas en prendre
conscience aujourd'hui il en prendra
conscience un jour c'est à dire dans
quelques mois lorsqu'il y aura un autre
verdict qui sera celui l'élection
présidentielle on va parler des
conséquences des régionales pour votre
party les républicains les républicains
qui ont gardé leur région en métropole
tout du moins est ce que quand même les
régionales elles vont laisser des traces
dans votre parti à ce qu'elles n'ont pas
mis en lumière finalement deux lignes
qui étaient très claires et qui était
peut-être irréconciliables écoutez il ya
quelques semaines on nous annonçait un
échec colossal
aujourd'hui on a une magnifique victoire
sur l'ensemble de notre pays
c'est une bonne nouvelle vous nous
permettrait de prendre un peu de plaisir
aussi à ce que nous ayons une réussite
une réussite électorale non on a réussi
à tenir cette ligne là qu'il aligne la
droite républicaine qui n'est ni la
remorque eu de marine le pen ni la
remorque du de la république en marche
et moi je les fais dans ma région en
menant une campagne que je considère
courageuse parce que c'est comme ça que
je les mener en étant fier d'avoir
éliminé au premier tour la république en
marche en étant aujourd'hui le plus près
possible du rassemblement national
alors qu'il ya quelques années ils
étaient deux fois plus nombreux dans
l'hémicycle
donc quand on tient sa ligne et sa
colonne vertébrale en avance mais c est
l asia la ligne est ce que c'est la
ligne de renaud muselier qui finalement
l'a remporté à remporter sa région
faisant une alliance de premier tour
avec des marcheurs ou est ce que c'est
la ligne par exemple de laurent wauquiez
qui lui en veut également porter sa
région des temps très clair sur pas
d'alliance avec le créa blick en marche
et en faisant
chute et le rassemblement national dans
sa région notre j'ai la gueule la ligne
notre ligne c'est celle de la droite
républicaine
il faut que vous sortiez de la tête
cette idée selon laquelle nous devrions
être condamnés à être les sous-fifres
des uns ou des autres nous réussirons
ont réussi rond lorsque nous assumerons
ce que nous sommes en train de faire
depuis plusieurs mois d'être nous mêmes
la droite républicaine et sociale de la
nation engage même chose par exemple
mais heureux on a eu ce débat moi je
pense que renaud muselier dont je salue
la magnifique victoire parce qu'elle
était incroyable mérité au regard du
travail qu'il a fait comme prise en
région il aurait pu gagner aussi bien
mort a encore mieux sans avoir ses
premiers ses premières semaines
douloureuse et pour le reste je pense
que nos concitoyens lors de cette
élection régionale au delà d'envoyer un
message très dur à emmanuel macron ont
aussi envoyé un message très dur à
marine le pen
on le dit peu parce que parce que la
scène qu'on nous avait installé consisté
à dire que marine le pen allait exploser
tous les plafonds la réalité si c'est un
échec colossal pour marine le pen un peu
dire de le répéter donc je le répète et
ça il faut le dire et le répéter parce
que le match qu'on veut nous installer
marine le pen
emmanuel macron je pense qu'il n'existe
que dans les commentaires et dans les
sondages dans l'esprit des français
la droite oui justement parce que les
sondages en l'occurrence celui d'el
abily heerden xavier bertrand en premier
candidat delà de la droite à 14%
seulement au premier tour vous retrouvez
finalement avec une abondance de biens
on vous avez trois grands présidents de
région valérie pécresse laurent wauquiez
xavier bertrand qui sont longs et très
très bien réélu et qui se trouvent être
des candidats putatifs pour 2022
une question c'est que la tendre
novembre pour désigner un candidat alors
même que l'un d'entre eux et xavier
bertrand a commencé sa campagne depuis
quasiment un an
si ce n'est officiellement bien en tout
cas officieusement
est-ce que c'est pas trop tard et ce
qu'on pas grave on perd pas beaucoup de
temps là dedans et c'est trop tard
sûrement bourreau pour vous parce qu'il
va falloir encore vous attendiez le mois
de novembre
on est quand même la pression sur la
direction du parti en disant il faut
bien même des débats l'intérieur du pays
ils sont très intéressants on m'a
toujours dit que la première qualité des
sénateurs c'était le sens fois le calme
j invite mes collègues sénateurs à faire
preuve de sang-froid de calme et le sang
froid et le calme c'est un message
politique sommes dans un moment où je
vous la sur les français qui est à + 60
% d'entre eux ne sont pas allés voter
pour les élections régionales ne sont
pas du tout dans l'obsession de savoir
comment les républicains vont organiser
un système qui permettra de désigner
leur candidat en novembre ça suffira
largement d'ailleurs c'est ce qui s'est
toujours passé puisque vous parler
d'histoire politique tout à l'heure
nicolas sarkozy jacques chirac
ce sont 13 le contexte c'était le soir
au g15 se sont dit souvent allez perdre
les rayons des régionales sont tous
gagnants trajet est ce qui manque de
sang froid de nicolas sarkozy et jacques
chirac se sont annoncées au mois de
novembre et à l'époque
à l'époque c'était différent
d'aujourd'hui vous avez raison
aujourd'hui même en novembre même en
novembre ce sera très tôt et jeudi à
l'ensemble de mes collègues sénateurs
que dans un moment où nous sortons
évidemment effectivement d'une victoire
à l'élection régionale
c'est pas le moment de perdre ses nerfs
c'est le moment d'adresser aux français
un message sérénité en leur disant nous
avons compris que vous vouliez nous
faire confiance qu'il faut qu'on
continue à se reconstruire sur le fond
et c'est pas le moment de se déchirer
sur les tapis du sénat ou de l'assemblée
nationale pour savoir qui sera notre
cahier est ce que nous le ferons et une
flore riche en octobre va pas arriver
naturellement étant donné que le
président des hauts de france candidat
refuse de participer à une primaire des
républicains
il ne veut passer
exactement et donc on sent bien qu'il
risque d'y avoir dès la rentrée toute
façon deux jeux de deux jeux qui vont
s'affronter avec des candidats encore
une fois pas déclaré laurent wauquiez
bruno retailleau et d'autres qui vont
vouloir un départage et un autre
candidat qui n'en voudra absolument pas
vous allez courir sur deux couloirs à la
fois comment vous faites vous je vous
remercie de nous vouloir le plus grand
bien
la réalité c'est qu'il ya encore
quelques de trois ans on use et nous
avions perd les élections municipales
on les a gagnés et quelques semaines on
disait qu'on allait perdre les élections
régionales
on les a gagnés et quelques mois on
disait que la droite était morte divisé
fracturée et qu'elle allait disparaître
elle est là solidement et aujourd'hui
notre problème c'est de gérer le trop
plein de talent alors qu'il ya quelques
temps on disait mais vous n'avez pas de
candidat je me disais mais qu'est il
n'avait pas de candidat à quelle horreur
et où est ce que vous allez me trouver
aujourd'hui on a trop à gérer
je le redis attend de novembre c'est
faire preuve de sérénité de
responsabilité et c'est un message
politique en soit avec une prime et
robin et jeudi que à la rentrée on vous
qu'est ce que vous pensez je suis
hostile à la primaire tel qu'on l'a vécu
parce que c'est une machine à diviser et
donc trouvions un autre système le
système de départage qui permettent que
de mai n'ayant qu'un seul candidat qui
je n'en sais rien et vous le disiez nous
avons nombreux talents autour de la
table je veux simplement dire à chacun
de mes collègues qui
se disent qu'ils peuvent devenir
président de la république que certains
sûrement peuvent le devenir
que d'autres savent déjà qu'ils ne
viendront jamais françois baroin par
exemple et que oui mais j'ai toujours
une fidélité à l'égard françois baroin
c'est moi je suis constant dans mes
soutiens et je veux donc dire à chacun
de ces candidats et sa ville espérait
encore sa candidature je le soutiens
jusqu'au jour il dira qu'il n'est plus
candidat il a clairement encore non il
me l'a pas dit clairement et peut-être
qu il le dira mais vous savez je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de fidélité
politique j'essaie de m'appliquer moi
même ce que je demande aux autres je
suis fidèle à son héritage politique
celui de jacques chirac et à la
personnalité qui est celle de françois
baroin mais nous verrons
est ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
la droite républicaine à une immense
responsabilité qui est de transformer le
pays demain et d'être au rendez-vous de
la confiance des français ça veut donc
dire que parmi tous ceux qui se
considèrent être extrêmement talentueux
pour être président de la république il
faudra qu'ils soient assez talentueux
aussi pour se ranger derrière celui qui
aura le plus de chances de l'emporter
et ça nous le verrons en ouvrant merci
beaucoup aurélien pradié vous viendrez
nous en parle et on espère merci
d'arrêter notre invité ce matin l'on
regarde la une de la voix du nord c'est
l'été est la une de la voix du nord le
guide de l'été 112 pages avec des idées
de sorties et de loisirs en famille ça
fait beaucoup d'idées du coup exactement
venez dans notre région pour en profiter
merci julien remercierez lien entre à
dire
[Musique]